okay hello everyone I'm so excited to be
here at CSS conf and talk to you all
about the algorithms of CSS what is this
talking to me about um so hello so my
name is Laura shank and that's my
Twitter handle I am a freelance
WordPress and front-end developer and
WordPress and CSS are kind of my my two
loves as well as teaching I love
teaching I love sharing what I know and
I also love using teaching as a means to
get myself to learn things which is kind
of what I did with this talk so CSS it
has a special place in my heart as I'm
sure it does most of us here I have a
background in art and I came upon CSS
through kind of a weird college project
college art project where I wanted to
turn it into a video game and that kind
of morphed into making WordPress sites
for money and that eventually turned
into a career I really loved and
computer science didn't really turn up
in my career until about three years ago
or so I kind of got really good at
making websites but didn't necessarily
understand what was happening under the
surface and this showed up in the form
of an algorithms interview how many of
us have done an algorithms like
whiteboarding interview before okay good
I'm at hand so like questionable
interviewing style but it exists so that
was kind of my first encounter I
definitely failed it and then about a
year ago I got an interview for a job I
was like very excited about I was like
okay I gotta take this one seriously and
I got to learn about computer science so
I really grew to love it and the
connection between computer science and
CSS wasn't always clear like I saw the
connections between my work with
JavaScript and with PHP quite often but
with CSS it was kind of hard to bridge
that gap so in the spirit of committing
to teach things in order to learn them I
proposed this talk for CSS coffee you
and I started my research for this kind
about six months ago
and CSS really went from something like
this so gray like I was like I gotta
write CSS like it's just not as
interesting as this other programming
stuff I'm doing and then over this six
months of research CSS became like oh my
god CSS is so cool like boss is the
dream this is awesome and in addition to
this kind of like revitalization of my
love for CSS my code got a lot better
and a lot more intentional and I think
um I wrote code I write code faster now
too so now we're gonna share with you
all how I got to that point and my
journey in this this research okay so I
started all this with a question is CSS
a programming language how many of you
have thought about this before okay good
nice number of hands I'm gonna follow
this up with a little fire emoji because
this is a little bit of a hot topic
lately and I posed this question on
Twitter is CSS a programming language
and the results were about as expected
42 42 % no 50% or rather 42 % yes 50 %
no 8% I'm not sure and the responses for
this tweet were interesting the yeses
were kind of like like yes absolutely
it's a programming language or like for
sure CSS is a programming language and
the nose were more like I don't know
like you can't really call programming a
web page layout you can't you don't
really say you program in CSS and HTML
it's like not really what it what it's
like so kind of fold this over and I was
like okay stop like I think we might be
getting some opinions and like personal
experience mixed up with facts here so
let's start by asking what is a
programming language and groundbreaking
definition coming up a language of
instructions for a computer so the thing
is but the definition of a programming
language is kind of intentionally vague
and there are many many types of
programming languages soon after reading
about the definition of a programming
language one would encounter programming
pair
and if the term paradigm is really word
for like a general classification or
model or style of doing something and
there are two main classifications in
programming paradigms there's imperative
programming paradigm which refers to
code that tells the computer how to do
something and there's declarative which
is code that tells the computer what to
do so these are two fundamentally
different paradigms and they are the two
main umbrellas and so with paradigms
languages can be categorized under
certain paradigms but they can also
describe like styles of the code that
you're writing so for example you might
be writing JavaScript in a more
imperative style or you can write it in
a more declarative style so they can be
high-level terms but also terms for
specific definitions and the two rather
the main difference between imperative
and declarative languages is the
presence of control flow in imperative
languages and control flow refers to the
ability to manipulate the order of
execution execution of statements in a
program and that happens via things like
if statements and for loops in a very
literal sense so you're the computer
would read your program kind of top to
bottom and then based on your program it
would look maybe jump up to different
parts of the code so you're manipulating
that order of execution and declarative
programming does not have control flow
so any logic or iteration is kind of
baked into the actual instructions
themselves like what you're telling the
computer to do is declarative okay there
are some languages that fall under these
categories imperative languages are what
we usually think of as programming
languages so JavaScript Ruby C++ Python
generally if you think of a programming
language it's probably an imperative
language declarative languages on the
other hand are oftentimes
domain-specific which means they've been
developed to function was in a certain
context and within a certain domain um
what are some domain-specific
programming languages hmm sequel is one
so sequel is a domain-specific
declarative language for working with
databases HTML what is sure hTML is the
domain-specific declarative language and
of course
CSS okay
sure there were people who would be like
uh what are you talking know now just
know like CSS is not doesn't count you
know whether you want to argue like CSS
was never intended to be something like
a programming language or perhaps that
the browser can't really count and you
know the browser just parses it doesn't
do anything else um to that I would say
like CSS plus HTML is also true and
complete and Turing complete refers to
the ability to solve a computer
computational problem of a certain
complexity CSS can also do math like
that's cool function and functions and
variables CSS also has but ultimately I
would say like why not so why can't CSS
and HTML for that matter be part of what
we consider programming languages so the
idea of kind of disqualifying HTML and
CSS leads to disqualifying all of
declarative languages so I think that
discrepancy comes into play when people
are misinterpreting what imperative
versus declarative is further the web at
large is really declarative in nature so
if we had to describe in our programs
how a computer supposed to or how a
browser is supposed to open a connection
to a server that will be like very very
intense and totally inaccessible so the
power of declarative programming is huge
especially when it comes to api's and
anything we do on the web okay so here
this loud and clear CSS is a
domain-specific declarative programming
language 100% and another another one we
as CSS developers program the layout of
web pages I'll give that another hundred
percent and so referring to what I would
do as a CSS developer as programming has
taken a long time to get used to that
but as I learn more and more about how
computers work and how a browser works
the code I write I think can totally
count as programming okay now we've
established got that all the way let's
talk about how their rhythms algorithms
101 yay okay let's have another
definition an algorithm is a well
defined computational procedure that
takes input and produces
put this is a definition taken from
Thomas Corman's introduction to
algorithms which is one of these you
know large textbooks assigned for
computer science courses dense very
informative maybe not a great intro but
hopefully this will be let's use this
format to this framework to talk about
algorithms so we have inputs unsorted
list and we have outputs maybe a sorted
list so what is the algorithm in between
there well
sorting is certainly a solved problem in
computer science we have lots of sorting
algorithms bubble sort is one was a
great name not the most performant of
sorting algorithms but it's excellent a
selection sort we also have merge sort
and quicksort let's take a look at an
implementation of one of these just to
kind of take a look at what an algorithm
is under the under the hood so why not
bubble sort this is what a sorting
algorithm looks like if anybody has
never seen one so let already read for a
moment wonderful bubble sort and all of
its glory so we can see this is
imperative JavaScript here we're really
telling the computer how to sort we're
giving it step-by-step instructions beat
to be read top down and the control flow
is there so we're gonna jumping back up
to certain statements where necessary
I'll give this a heart because I like
JavaScript if this were a declarative
program this is all you would see okay
back to our framework
how would algorithms we're out of
extinct like this apply to CSS okay
let's say we have a stack of elements so
to speak and our output would be a row
of elements what would be an algorithm
we would use in in declarative CSS to
get there I'm sorry what would be an
algorithm we would use to get there
display flex sure why not that's totally
an algorithm or perhaps float:left
yes okay let's take a close look at the
implementation of this algorithm okay
there it is display flex that's
declarative CSS so I'll give us a heart
because that's amazing that we can just
like that's display flex okay I just did
a ton of stuff and I didn't have to
write all that code I didn't have to
write that how so that's the power of
declarative programming um it's kind of
the dream I think like what we do with
CSS okay so the thing is there is of
course a how-to declarative programs we
write the what and we need to understand
the how to make our code better let's
have an iceberg metaphor okay so we have
imperative or rather declarative on the
top and imperative at the bottom so when
it comes to CSS the the imperative part
is gonna be our our the rather the
declared apart is gonna be our iceberg
at the top and the C++ and rust code
that lies within a browsers rendering
engine is what we have at the bottom so
I like as I was learning all this I'm
like okay I want to like look at this
imperative CSS like what is that what is
there so I started by taking a look at
the Cascade I love the Cascade in CSS so
not only is the Cascade wonderful it's
also the first thing that shows up when
you search algorithms and CSS so it
cascaded an algorithm that combines
property values from different sources
that is from Mozilla developer Network
if we place this into our algorithms
framework we start with inputs from
different sources and our outputs our
combined values from those different
sources and what's the algorithm in
between what happens in between so we
sort by importance and origin sort by
specificity and finally the order
specified and that winning value is
what's then sent to the browser's
rendering engine okay so I was like ok I
understood the Cask I understood the
Cascade like this is not groundbreaking
information
I'm guessing a lot of us here understand
the Cascade I wanted to see what it
looked like and I expect to defend
something like this like function
cascade magic and that's pretty much
what I found
it's like function cascade like look at
it it's right there though the thing is
this is more of like a fun slide because
the Cascade happens in many many you
know hundreds of maybe thousands level
lines of code throughout those sorts of
CSS and can't really be pinpointed to
one file but I was like ah this is
definitely going in slides okay where
did I find this code like I know you all
are dying to spend the weekend looking
through rust and C++ so when you go to
search fox org which is a searchable
repository of firefox as well as CS
chromium.org which is the searchable
repository of chromium and specifically
we want to look at the rendering engine
eating ship D so in Firefox that
rendering engine is called servo and in
chromium rather chrome it's called blink
so blink is the open source rendering
engine there that's also used in opera
so my process for looking through these
these source files was to read the spec
very carefully and I would kind of go
step by step through this and map what I
was reading in the spec to the source
code which was a nice process because
browsing browser source code aimlessly
is gets a little bit tedious um another
thing I want to point out that became
like way more apparent and meaningful or
the just the simple names of what we
call things in CSS so we're all probably
familiar with the idea of selector
property and value um but this is called
a declaration I often called this a rule
and this whole thing is called a rule
and it's really important to or rather
these terms became way more meaningful
after I'd had this experience of looking
through the browser um
because the like CSS is parsed
specifically to retrieve each of these
values okay so whatever the Cascade like
it exists and the browser got it this is
when my CSS this was when I kind of had
this look you know what enlightenment
moment where I was like CSS and then I
was like oh my god so cool
see all stuff happening underneath like
this wonderful so um and and I think
that's where I pay you know every line
of code I would write and like I see
this other part and it was just amazing
so I suggested for everybody um I don't
look at a specific example and to get
back to algorithms a little bit more and
about how am i my code and like my style
of writing code changed after this so
this was a wonderful mock-up that I
received from one of my clients as an
agency and this is a drawing of the
mock-up let me be be clear and that is a
high-resolution image of an ocean on top
if you can't tell so wait the design was
done really well really intentionally a
kind of developer friendly and we talked
about how this design would break down
and we were gonna have two different
images here so the bottom will be this
transparent PNG and the top would be
like a compressed JPEG and then you know
all the sizing could be done with aspect
ratios and whatnot so I started coding
this and everything was great and then I
was like oh crap like the ratios are
really different in the mobile comm
versus the desktop comp and I was like
this is fresh this is a fun challenge
like okay but I'm getting annoyed and I
began programming my CSS with a hammer
so like if anybody's sure we've all done
this before where you're just like oh my
god like work and you just kind of keep
trying the same ten things over and over
in your head and you're like it's kind
of different but not but maybe it'll
work this time so I was like okay stop
don't do that I'm writing this whole
talk about algorithms and like
algorithmic thinking in CSS what if I
break this down into an algorithms
problem so what are the inputs beautiful
ocean image number one beautiful ocean
in dimension number two and my viewport
of course and what are the outputs
everything smashed together because s
CSS developers we are programmers of
boxes essentially so what position are
those boxes gonna be in now I'd write an
algorithm for this I was like oh crap
how do I write an algorithm well I've
been studying for these ridiculous white
boarding interviews here are the steps
you take to write an algorithm in an
white boarding interview so step one you
plan it out you pick plan out your
inputs and your outputs and kind of
steps you're gonna take in between so
pseudocode and number two you come up
with a brute force solution and your
brute force solution is a not performant
solution for the algorithm you're kind
of just getting it done but getting it
to work so with something like
brute-force search you would rather than
algorithmically or efficiently group
certain elements and search in a more
strategized way you would just go step
by step like is this the one no is this
the one no this one no so that's the
idea of route force third step you would
walk through so like check and see if
your algorithm works for step optimize
your solution so apply different
strategies for algorithms designed to
whatever your brute force solution was
and kind of refactor it okay great
so planning kind of talked about the
inputs and outputs already I took to my
white board and figured out how I wanted
these boxes to change at different
viewport sizes and then came back and
mapped out different values and
different behaviors that I wanted for
this specific layout then I jumped into
some pseudocode I was like okay I was
like pseudocode for CSS cool that's not
something I usually do but this is
really helpful um so number two I'll go
to my brute force solution and another
word for brute force solution is
spaghetti like spaghetti code I was like
oh okay this is when this brute force
step is when you have permission to
write bad code it's like oh it's okay I
don't have to think about all the naming
conventions and everything I just want
to figure out the solution to a problem
and I'd never really approached CSS that
way like that's how I would approach
JavaScript in PHP but that's not
something I did in CSS brute force CSS
what do we got smelly CSS so what are
some qualities of brute force CSS is it
part of a system No so if you're working
within a design system I'm not sure how
many of us have the luxury of doing that
but scrap your design system for a
second and just be like oh I got to
figure out this weird problem I'm not
gonna try to do it within the confines
of this system which is wonderful but
it's like a hindrance right now magic
numbers absolutely to do comments
absolutely
does it work maybe but pretty much
you're like figuring that out so it
might work
step three walk through this is one we
can have do that wonderful browser
resizing that we developers love to do
not sure if users do that but we like to
do it so make note of what works and
what doesn't
then fourth step optimize our brute
force CSS and refactor so optimizes code
for a refactor so we take our wonderful
smelly CSS and it magically transforms
into a beautiful flower of optimized CSS
freedom I know this was I might have had
the most fun making this slide I was
like this one's gonna go down well
okay so optimize CSS what are some
qualities I've often my CSS part of his
system yes so this is when you have your
like brute force code you're like Oh
gross but I'm gonna massage it back into
the design system or the naming
conventions that you're using um
uses algorithm so does it take advantage
of the algorithm intrinsic algorithms
that are baked into CSS so like CSS grid
algorithms um
intentional cascade I like this one
because obviously I love the Cascade
after doing all of this and so I'm like
how can I use the Cascade here cascade
an inheritance oh it's like baked into
the name of CSS let's use it to do
comments there are all gonna be gone but
a lot of them will be okay small note
here this is kind of to me we all write
CSS differently all of our teams write
CSS differently so these are kind of
some qualities have optimized CSS that I
shoot for okay
rollover of code here and preface it
with a yellow light because as this code
is taken out of context and might not
make entire sense us mashed into a slide
but these are things I kind of consider
algorithms in CSS and ways I've solved
followed this process to solve a problem
so this is the solution to the ocean
ocean boxes issue then we have
a centering algorithm
and finally yeah this buzz yeah I failed
fizzbuzz in an interview like three
years ago and so now I'm like all right
take that fizzbuzz and CSS do it so if
anybody gets asked fizzbuzz in an app in
an interview please write it in CSS and
if you're not familiar with fizzbuzz it
is one of these kind of beginner
algorithms questions that is intended to
like stumped people it's not not very
nice it's well-meaning and initially but
I know so after doing all this and kind
of figure out this new process for
writing CSS for myself I was like oh my
god
dad come up with a new thing like could
this be algorithms in CSS it's like a
new way of writing CSS or maybe I was
like I got to give it a name
maybe algorithmic CSS or maybe intrinsic
algorithmic CSS I was like oh maybe and
then I was like hmm okay
maybe I just got better at writing CSS
so but I think I'm interested to hear
from everybody kind of throughout the
after the conference like how you use
algorithms I mean if this makes sense um
okay so I wanna wrap up a little bit
with a tip that I think anybody who
works within this design to development
process can hopefully take back to help
smooth out that process because
unfortunately it is not all puppies and
kittens
I like expressions so here's a designer
and developer puppy and kitten so I
think that we can use algorithms as a
common term to talk about how our
designs are supposed to respond across
device sizes and of course I don't want
to leave out the designer developer
algorithms yay okay so what did what
would this look like I guess this
conversation so we think about we have
small screens
okay and we have big screens and we have
a component here that is changing based
on the screen size so I think in in this
conversation that's designed to
development conversation whether it's
just with you as one person or with with
a group with a team we can think about
the resize rules so what are the resize
rules what's the the component resize
rules for this particular element or you
know algorithm maybe
try it on for size oh here's a little
example of one of my projects one of the
agencies I work with was doing this
already and I was like okay that's great
and I'm gonna put this in my talk so
they would kind of include a little
description of a component with the
design for the pattern and I was like
awesome pseudocode done I don't have to
be this part anymore cuz we go back to
our four step algorithms writing process
our planning step is done now that's
great and here's the resulting algorithm
for that little bit of code magic maybe
okay hey conclusion here we go okay if
you take away one thing from this talk
it is that iceberg metaphors are amazing
okay just kidding
but I wanted to be that the code we
write is kind of at the top the tip of
the iceberg here so it's what we see and
how it works is all the way down there
so it's not something we necessarily see
and that's something we have to seek out
and try to see for ourselves and kind of
fill in those gaps where we can and
filling in those gaps and constructing
the bottom of the iceberg we really help
the code we write at the top be a lot
more informed and a lot more intentional
also this idea for early annoying app
that would be the mindful CSS Belle and
it would go off every 30 minutes and it
would kind of catch you and make sure
you're not writing CSS with a hammer and
it would say like read the spec so it's
like do you understand what this little
line of code it's doing that you're
writing so I haven't made this happen am
I not but that's an idea so the end of
the day did I bridge the gap between CSS
and computer science like I intended to
well I think it was a lot more like this
so we have computer science and within
computer science we have CSS and we have
C++ and we have HTML and we have a
JavaScript and many many other things
and so really that's all it's all great
I love it okay yay
thank you everyone
[Applause]
and this is a
[Applause]
this uh this link is linking to a blog
post where it's a very large compendium
of a lot of the sources I used for
learning how our browser works and
learning more about computer science so
thank you all looking forward to talking
to you later
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]